.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Sanfte Musik *
Was, wenn das Kind mit einer
Beeinträchtigung zur Welt kommt?
Was macht eine Familie aus?
Wie funktioniert
ein Leben mit Downsyndrom?
Wir begleiten Janusch
fünf Jahre lang mit der Kamera.
(Alle) # Zum Geburtstag viel Glück.
# Zum Geburtstag viel Glück.
# Zum Geburtstag, lieber Janusch,
zum Geburtstag viel Glück.
Oh!
Bravo!
Dass Janusch heute
seinen ersten Geburtstag feiern kann,
ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Kurz nach seiner Geburt brachte ihn
nämlich ein Darmverschluss
an den Rand von Leben und Tod.
Eine häufige Komplikation
bei Downsyndrom.
Einen Monat musste er
auf der Intensivstation verbringen,
bevor er nach Hause durfte.
* Sanfte Musik *
Olga Jappert Vonmoos
war 30 Jahre alt,
als sie Janusch erwartete.
Im besten Alter gewissermassen.
Träumen wir noch?
Knapp zwei Jahre zuvor hatte sie
bereits einen Jungen geboren: Thorin.
Keinerlei Anlass also, sich während
der Schwangerschaft Sorgen zu machen.
Als die Hebamme
dann kurz nach Januschs Geburt
den Verdacht äusserte,
der Kleine habe das Downsyndrom,
waren die jungen Eltern
erst einmal verunsichert.
Hast du lange geschlafen?
- Bei mir.
(Flüsternd)
Heute ist dein Fest, Janusch.
Was, wenn das Kind mit einer
Beeinträchtigung zur Welt kommt?
Weder Olga noch ihr Mann Michi
hatten sich bisher
ernsthaft mit dieser Frage
auseinandergesetzt.
Plötzlich kam in mir das Gefühl auf:
Was heisst das eigentlich?
Kann das auch heissen,
dass er Schmerzen hat
und gesundheitlich nicht ... äh ...
Dass er gesundheitlich
Probleme haben wird?
Oder was heisst das alles?
Und dann fing ich an,
mir Sorgen zu machen.
Ich kam damit nicht zurecht.
Als ich dann mit der Hebamme redete,
wir miteinander sprachen
und es hiess, dass das
nicht bedeute, dass er leide,
war die Freude umso grösser,
also die Spannung darauf, was uns
dieses Leben noch bringen würde.
Eines von weltweit 700 Babys
hat das Downsyndrom,
auch Trisomie 21 genannt.
Dabei handelt es sich
um eine Veränderung des Erbguts.
In jeder einzelnen Zelle
ist das Chromosom 21 nicht doppelt,
sondern dreifach vorhanden.
Für nichts auf der Welt
würde ich dieses Chromosom
wieder hergeben.
Das hat im Leben so viel ausgelöst.
So viel! So viel Positives.
Ja.
Gut!
Vorher war alles wie logisch.
Es würde die Schulzeit kommen,
das und jenes.
Es war wie alles aufgelöst.
Es ist so ...
Dadurch bin ich plötzlich
viel freier in den Chancen,
die wir haben.
* Ruhige Musik *
Olga Jappert Vonmoos ist Bildhauerin.
Heute besucht sie
den Steinbruch in Liesberg.
Hier holt sie Jurakalk
für die Arbeit im Atelier.
Hallo, Beat.
- Hallo.
Welchen? Den hier?
- Ja.
Ah, ja.
Zunächst
studierte die Baselbieterin Kunst,
aber das war ihr zu wenig konkret.
Deshalb machte sie
die vierjährige Bildhauerlehre
und stieg dann
ins Geschäft ihres Vaters ein.
Das brachte auch einen weiteren,
grossen Vorteil:
Mit den Grosseltern
in der unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft
kann sie Arbeit und Familie
optimal verbinden.
Dachten Sie daran, mit der Arbeit
aufzuhören, als die Kinder kamen?
Nein.
Nein. Das hatten wir
schon zuvor miteinander besprochen:
Wenn es überhaupt
so weit kommen sollte,
wäre es klar,
dass beide weiterarbeiten wollen.
Wir wollten auf irgendeine Art
und Weise einen Weg finden,
wie es lösbar ist.
Aber den Beruf aufgeben - nein.
Ich glaube,
dazu müsste ich gezwungen werden,
wenn es wirklich
nichts mehr zu verdienen gäbe.
Olga Jappert Vonmoos hat keine vor-
geburtlichen Untersuchungen gemacht,
obwohl seit einigen Jahren ein
einfacher Bluttest auf dem Markt ist,
der Trisomie
sehr zuverlässig erkennen kann.
Seit 2015 wird dieser
von der Krankenkasse bezahlt.
Laut Studien entscheiden sich bei
Trisomie-Verdacht über 90 % der Paare
für eine Abtreibung.
Das wäre für Olga und ihren Mann
nie infrage gekommen.
Man solle versuchen,
die Steine wegzuräumen,
die das Schicksal
einem in den Weg lege, findet Olga.
Und sie als Bildhauerin habe da noch
ganz andere Werkzeuge zur Verfügung.
Vielleicht,
weil ich jetzt gelernt habe,
mich an Steine heranzuwagen,
die einem in den Weg gelegt werden.
Also sie zu bearbeiten.
Aus ihnen kann man etwas machen,
das man brauchen kann,
oder etwas, das schön ist,
wenn sie einem im Weg liegen,
also vor der Nase.
Und das
war wahrscheinlich nicht immer so.
Das muss man irgendwie lernen.
Vielleicht
ist das mit Janusch noch extremer.
Noch mehr ...
In diesem Jahr hat sich
so viel in diese Richtung verändert.
Ich könnte nicht so reden,
wenn etwas schiefgegangen
oder Janusch gestorben wäre.
Oder ... äh ...
Einfach all diese schwierigen
Sachen, wenn etwas schiefgeht.
Das Jahr seit Januschs Geburt
war schwierig und sorgenvoll
und stellte die junge Familie
auf eine harte Probe.
An ihrer Liebe aber
hat Olga nie gezweifelt.
Vielleicht
wird den Leuten zu wenig gesagt,
dass man darauf vertrauen kann,
dass man das Kind, das kommt,
auch liebt - egal, wie es ist
und wie es geboren wird.
Und das erleben Sie so?
- Mhm.
Es war auch immer klar.
Ich merke erst jetzt,
dass ich mehr Geschichten höre
von Leuten,
die es anders erleben,
damit nicht zurechtkommen oder so.
Und dann merke ich erst: "Aha!"
"Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass man das so sieht
und wahrnehmen kann."
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Kinderbetreuung
teilen sich Olga und Michi auf.
Dass sie Kinder wollten,
war ihnen bald einmal klar.
Und in grundlegenden Erziehungsfragen
sind sie sich einig.
Z.B. auch darin, dass sie
der freien Entwicklung ihrer Kinder
viel Raum geben wollen.
Wir waren nie diejenigen, die
unser Kind speziell fördern wollten
und das Ziel hatten,
dass es möglichst bald
das Gymnasium besuchen kann.
Und bei Janusch
ist es noch weniger der Fall.
Ja ... Muss es denn überhaupt
der normale Weg sein?
Oder kann es etwas total anderes ...
Also "total" ...
Kann es etwas anderes sein?
Wie viel kann und will man
sich herausnehmen?
Mal sehen.
Das gibt noch einige Diskussionen.
Ja, wir schauen mal, wohin es geht.
Ohne Förderung geht es aber nicht.
Daniela Odermatt, eine Logopädin,
kommt auf Hausbesuch.
Ganz, ganz nahe. Komm!
Die Katze kommt auch.
Sie beobachtet, wie Janusch isst.
Jetzt. Genau. Zungendruck!
Super! Das war ganz schön.
Perfekt!
Das Ziel ist, dass die Zunge
beim Essen möglichst drin ist.
Es gibt so einen Zungenstoss,
den man verhindern möchte.
Und das gelingt,
wenn man den Druck auf die Zunge
im richtigen Moment macht.
Dadurch lernt er
das richtige Schlucken,
sonst stösst es die Zunge.
Ja, ja.
Jetzt wird er müde.
Jetzt wird er etwas müde.
Am Anfang muss man Gas geben.
- Ja.
Nachher wird er müde.
Genau, jetzt wird er müde.
Durch die verminderte Körperspannung
ist das sehr anstrengend.
Und da wird er halt schnell müde,
um aufrecht zu bleiben, nicht wahr?
Nochmals.
Schau dort rüber! Schau!
- Janusch.
Schau dort rüber!
Jeder Löffel ein Kampf,
aber Aufgeben ist keine Option.
Jetzt.
- Ahm.
Genau: "Ahm!"
Du machst es gut vor.
Eben: Das hat Janusch
seit seiner Geburt bewiesen.
Er ist ein grosser Kämpfer.
Er hat enorm aufgeholt.
Als ich anfing,
war er hier einfach völlig schlaff.
Und es ist wichtig,
dass er auch andere Therapien hat -
Physiotherapie,
Frühförderung und alles Mögliche,
die alle
in dieselbe Richtung arbeiten,
dass sie unterstützend sind.
Und er hat sehr engagierte Eltern.
Sie setzen Dinge um, die man zeigt.
Und dann hat er die Chance,
einen Tonusaufbau zu machen,
weil er eben das Angebot bekommt.
Er ermüdet einfach sehr schnell.
Wie Sie sehen: zehn, zwölf Löffel
und dann wird er müde.
Man muss ihm helfen,
die Spannung hochzuhalten,
und darauf achten,
dass er durchhält.
Wichtig ist auch, dass der Becher
bis mindestens hierhin gefüllt ist.
Das hast du mir mal gesagt.
Denn sonst ...
Hier unten sind Noppen.
Sie kommen an die Lippen.
Sie geben ihm einen Impuls.
Und das Obere führt dazu,
dass er die Lippen darüberstülpt.
Jetzt käme der nächste Schritt:
Wenn die Oberlippe
die Flüssigkeit hier berührt,
wird das automatische Schlucken
ausgelöst.
Das wäre das Ziel, dass er das,
was wir selbstverständlich machen,
dann auch kann.
Ich muss gucken.
Die Förderung von Menschen
mit Trisomie 21
hat grosse Fortschritte gemacht.
Auch medizinisch sind die Prognosen
heute viel besser als früher.
Die Lebenserwartung
ist in den letzten Jahrzehnten
von 20 auf 60 Jahre angestiegen.
Diejenigen, die hier sind,
sind herzlich willkommen.
Die anderen sind nicht mehr hier.
Sie sind
gar nicht zur Welt gekommen.
Es ist auch eine gewisse Toleranz.
Ich erlebe einfach,
dass heute Kinder mit Downsyndrom,
die unterstützt werden,
sozial viel weiter kommen,
besser integriert sind
und schulisch besser sind.
Ich durfte Kinder unterstützen,
die mehrsprachig waren.
Sie sind sehr lange
in die Regelschule gegangen
und haben dort
sehr gute Ziele erreicht.
Aber auch hier
gibt es riesige Unterschiede.
Das ist ein grosser Fächer.
Man kann nicht
alle Downsyndrom-Kinder,
also Trisomie-Kinder,
in denselben Topf werfen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Janusch ist sehr herzlich willkommen,
das steht ausser Zweifel.
Seine Eltern haben sich
auf sein Tempo eingestellt.
Andere Kinder in seinem Alter
können sitzen und krabbeln,
manche können schon gehen.
Man weiss: Es dauert alles
viel länger, bis er etwas kann.
Dafür ist es umso schöner,
wenn er wieder etwas kann.
Da ist die Freude fast grösser
als bei Thorin.
Bei ihm weiss man:
Er kann das jetzt dann.
Es ist normal.
Und jetzt merkt man:
Es ist nicht einfach alles normal.
Es ist ... Ja ...
Es bereitet einem
eine riesige Freude,
wenn er wieder etwas kann.
Es stört mich gar nicht,
wenn es länger dauert.
Wir haben Zeit.
Wir haben keinen Stress,
er hat keinen Stress.
Auf Deutsch gesagt
ist es völlig wurst.
* Sanfte Musik *
Und doch:
Wieder steht einer
der zahlreichen Besuche
im Kinderspital beider Basel an.
Januschs Entwicklung
wird engmaschig ärztlich begleitet.
So, jetzt.
Gut!
Du hast eine schöne Körperspannung.
Das ist gut.
* Lachen *
Gut! Und ein schönes Gewicht.
Ah, gut!
Ich wäre froh, wenn Sie ihm
die Strumpfhose ausziehen könnten.
Aber ich finde, er hat einen schönen
Muskeltonus, das muss man sagen.
Er hängt nicht
wie ein schlaffer Sack.
Das haben wir oftmals.
Oh, das mag er nicht.
- Das magst du nicht?
Und zack! Jawohl.
Sehr gut!
Jetzt machen wir da auch einmal auf.
Ich will mir noch
seinen Rücken ansehen,
ob er gerade ist, wenn er sitzt.
Janusch.
Gut.
Er hat einen schönen Rücken.
Er geht nicht
in einen Rundrücken rüber.
Worauf man bei den Kindern
aber aufpassen muss:
Sie können auf die Seite hin eine
Wirbelsäulenverkrümmung bekommen.
Aber er sitzt schön und stabilisiert
eigentlich ganz gut.
Das ist das Wichtige.
Isst er schon etwas vom Tisch mit,
oder ...
Nein.
- Das nicht?
Also hauptsächlich Brei?
- Ähm ... Ja.
Es interessiert ihn, was es gibt,
aber er führt es nicht zum Mund.
Schaust du schnell oben?
- Ja.
Wir müssen nochmals. Komm.
Ist gut?
- Ja.
Ja. Nur 3 Sek.
- 71,2 cm.
Sieh, jetzt ist es schon wieder gut.
Und zuletzt noch etwas Erfreuliches:
Es gibt am Herzen
zwar einen kleinen Fehler,
aber sonst hat er eigentlich
keine grossen Probleme.
Untersucht man das nochmals?
- In einem Jahr.
Ich glaube, das Nächste ist sicher,
dass man sich darauf fokussiert,
dass er sicher und stabil
sitzen kann,
denn dann eröffnet sich für ihn
auch eine ganz andere Spielwelt.
Dann kann er ganz anders
am aktiven Leben teilnehmen.
Ich glaube,
das ist der nächste Punkt,
dass er das Krabbeln und Sitzen
lernt.
Das ist sicherlich eine Aufgabe
der Physiotherapie,
die Sie begleiten kann.
Deswegen finde ich es gut,
dass er das einmal pro Woche macht.
Man sollte eben auch darauf achten,
dass die Kinder
nicht übertherapiert werden.
Man muss sie auch
etwas davor schützen und sagen,
dass sie nicht mehr als zwei
Therapieformen bekommen sollen.
Von mehr
können sie noch nicht profitieren.
Und sie sollen sich auch
aus dem natürlichen Antrieb
weiterentwickeln können und nicht
nur von Therapie zu Therapie laufen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Schön.
Diesen ärztlichen Rat
nehmen sie sich zu Herzen.
Olga und Michi scheinen
in ihrem Elternsein gefestigt.
Ihr Lebensentwurf hat sich für
diese Familie als richtig erwiesen.
Generationenübergreifend arbeiten,
räumliche Nähe,
welche die Integration von Familie
in den Berufsalltag zulässt.
Und unbeschwert dank Nichtwissens.
Olga und Michi haben sich bewusst
gegen pränatale Diagnostik
entschieden -
nicht zuletzt auch deshalb,
weil sie nicht durch eine Diagnose
verunsichert werden wollen.
Inzwischen ist eine weitere
Erkenntnis immer stärker geworden:
Dank Janusch
hat sich ihr Horizont erweitert.
Durch ihn haben sie viele
bereichernde Erfahrungen gesammelt.
Hallo.
- Hallo, Gaby.
Der Familientreff in Binningen.
Einmal im Monat
gibt es hier ein Stelldichein
für Familien
mit Kindern mit Downsyndrom.
Der Moment,
als das Kind zur Welt kam,
ist für alle
noch in lebhafter Erinnerung.
Nein.
Es war total überraschend.
Bei der Geburt hat der Arzt gesagt:
"Ihr Kind hat Trisomie 21."
Wir wussten nicht, was das heisst.
Zu Beginn war es sehr schwierig.
Ich konnte es nicht akzeptieren.
Aber nach zwei, drei Monaten
hatte ich mich daran gewöhnt.
Gleiche Sorgen, gleiche Freuden
und gleiche Erfahrungen.
Du siehst ihnen die Unsicherheit
gleich in den Augen an.
Ich nehme es ihnen nicht übel,
aber ...
Nein, ich glaube,
ich hätte auch so reagiert.
Wir machten
eine Nackenfaltenmessung.
Diese war unauffällig. Da
machten wir uns keine Gedanken mehr.
Sie wäre so oder so
willkommen gewesen.
Wir haben es schon
in der Schwangerschaft erfahren.
Wir machten einen Pränataltest.
Wir wussten es schon
in der 19. Schwangerschaftswoche.
Am Anfang war es sicher ein Schock,
aber dann nahmen wir es so,
wie es kam. Jetzt ist es so.
Was, wenn das Kind mit einer
Beeinträchtigung zur Welt kommt?
Über diese Frage mussten sich hier
alle Gedanken machen.
Jetzt gehen wir zusammen raus.
* Ruhige Musik *
Zwei Jahre später:
Janusch ist vierjährig,
sein Bruder Thorin schon sechs.
Und: Die Familie Jappert Vonmoos
ist weiter gewachsen.
Vor einem Jahr
ist Arvid zur Welt gekommen,
der dritte Bub.
Die Schwangerschaft war nicht geplant
und hat das Leben der Familie
erneut völlig auf den Kopf gestellt.
Mental ist viel passiert
in dieser ganzen Schwangerschaft.
Das war wie ...
Man hat die ganzen Höhen
und Tiefen nochmals erlebt.
Die Ängste waren nochmals präsent.
Die Ängste ...
Das Bewusstsein,
dass ein Kind nach einer Geburt
ins Spital kommen könnte.
Dass man nicht einfach
nach Hause kann und alles ist gut.
Wir haben gesagt:
"Das kommt schon gut."
Nach dem ersten Schock.
- Ja.
Aber es war wirklich ein Schock.
- Was war der Schock?
Wir hatten das gar nicht erwartet.
"Schaffen wir das?"
Wir wussten, dass wir mit Janusch
schon viel zu tun haben.
Er gibt mehr Arbeit
als jetzt z.B. Thorin.
Da mussten wir uns
erst mal ein bisschen sammeln
und darauf einstellen.
Und das machten wir.
Jetzt sind wir zufrieden. Es passt.
Ich hatte schlichtweg Angst davor,
überfordert zu sein.
Graben wir weiter?
Trotz der Sorgen:
Auch bei dieser Schwangerschaft haben
sie auf pränatale Tests verzichtet.
Das sei nie ein Thema gewesen,
sagen sie.
Eingebettet zwischen zwei Brüdern hat
Janusch grosse Fortschritte gemacht.
Vieles, was schwierig war
und bisweilen unüberwindbar schien,
läuft inzwischen
sehr selbstverständlich.
Essen z.B.
bereitet ihm kaum mehr Mühe.
Trinken aber
ist noch immer kompliziert.
Michi oder ich
geben immer den Schoppen.
So drei- bis viermal pro Tag. Mhm.
Er trinkt auch sonst nichts.
Das ist die einzige Flüssigkeit,
die er zu sich nimmt.
Wir verdünnen die Milch einfach.
Aber wenn sie zu dünn ist,
kommt er nicht zurecht damit.
Dann rutscht bzw. fliesst sie
zu schnell runter.
Er muss mit der Konsistenz
umgehen können, mit der Zunge.
Ich weiss es nicht genau.
* Ruhige Musik *
Wohnen und arbeiten
in unmittelbarer Nachbarschaft -
dieses Konzept
hat sich für die Familie bewährt.
Dennoch: Das Leben mit den drei Buben
ist turbulent.
Finnland gegen die Türkei.
Kürzlich sagte jemand,
sie würden glauben,
wir seien
eine unglaublich chaotische Familie.
Da musste ich erst lachen
und dachte ...
Meine beste Freundin lachte auch.
Sie kennt mich so gut.
Ich bin so das Gegenteil
von chaotisch.
Ich will alles schön geordnet.
Und im Nachhinein dachte ich dann:
"Es könnte sein,
dass ich chaotisch geworden bin."
Anders geht es gar nicht.
Erstens mal wegen der drei Kinder
und zweitens wegen Janusch.
Da herrschen
so andere Gesetzmässigkeiten,
dass man einfach ...
... ein Chaot wird.
Ja, ja.
* Lachen *
Ja, da schmunzelt man einfach
und bleibt ruhig.
Das ist Alltag.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Seit ein paar Wochen
besucht Janusch den Kindergarten.
Im Dorf
gibt es keine geeignete Institution,
deshalb muss der Vierjährige
mit dem Schulbus nach Sissach.
Ein grosser Schritt
Richtung Selbstständigkeit.
* Fröhliche Musik *
(Alle) # Ich strecke mich nach oben,
# die Hände nun zu Boden.
# Ich wackle mit dem Po.
# Und bin jetzt einfach froh.
Jedes Kind hier
wird einzeln gefördert.
Wann sich
welche Kompetenzen einstellen,
ist bei Kindern mit Downsyndrom
schwer vorauszusagen.
Wir machen UK.
Wir arbeiten und spielen.
"Hey, Hund,
ich will auch in den Bus."
Und da ist eine Schnecke.
* Unverständlich *
Mach es zu.
Zu. Schau mal:
* Sie grunzt. *
"Ich möchte auch in den Bus sitzen."
* Er ahmt sie nach. *
Gut.
Eins, zwei ...
... drei.
Drei, genau.
Drei Mäuschen gehen in den Bus.
Jetzt ist der Bus voll.
Fertig Kopfmassage.
Fertig.
Janusch kann noch nicht sprechen,
deshalb übt Seraina Jeker
mit ihm Gebärdensprache.
Da muss man lachen, oder?
Es soll für ihn
eine Erleichterung sein.
Einerseits,
damit er auch besser versteht.
Wenn man "Mama" sagt,
erleichtert das die Sache für ihn.
Sonst ist das sehr abstrakt.
Wir sprechen auch viel und schnell.
Mit Gebärden spricht man
automatisch auch langsamer.
So wird das Tempo etwas gedrosselt.
Und er kann uns besser mitteilen,
wenn er etwas von der Katze
erzählen möchte.
So verstehen wir ihn auch schneller.
Es soll eine Unterstützung für
die Verbalsprache sein, kein Ersatz.
Das ist dein Papa.
Er kommt hierher.
Gut.
Man merkt,
wie er versucht, sich mitzuteilen,
wie er gebärdet, wie er anfängt,
die Sprache zu lernen.
Er kommt nach Hause
und versucht zu erzählen.
In ruhigen Momenten,
bevor er einschläft,
ist er wie eine Quelle.
Dann ist es ruhiger,
die anderen sind nicht da.
Ich glaube, du hast genug.
Lass uns das machen.
Hm? Machen wir das?
Dann versucht er, zu erzählen.
Dann merkt man,
was alles passiert ist.
Wir wissen nicht genau,
was er im Kindergarten macht.
Man sieht eine Wesensveränderung.
Ein paar Stunden jeden Tag
ist Janusch in diesem
heilpädagogischen Kindergarten.
(Jeker) Wir machen sie kaputt.
Ihm gefällt es und seiner Mutter
verschafft es etwas Raum und Ruhe.
Oh, jetzt sind alle weg.
Zu wissen,
dass er in diesem Kindergarten ist
und in den nächsten vier Jahren
nicht schon wieder wechseln muss ...
Er ist einfach mal an einem Ort.
Das entlastet extrem.
Also, das ist keine Last ...
Vielleicht ist es eher eine Sorge,
die das wegnimmt.
Man kann abgeben, teilen.
Es ist wunderschön, das zu erleben.
Möchtest du auch DAR-VIDA?
- Ja.
DAR-VIDA. Hoppla. Jawohl.
Uh!
Janusch, nein.
Hey, er ist nicht herangekommen.
Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Ja, gut.
Will sonst noch jemand Chips?
Annina, möchtest du Chips?
- Ja.
Ich möchte Chips.
- So. Da.
Und Beni, möchtest du Chips?
(Olga) Obwohl es manchmal
fast unaushaltbar streng ist,
würde ich trotzdem nichts ändern -
finde ich jetzt.
Ich bin extrem glücklich -
mit dem, was ich mache
und wie wir zusammen sind.
Einfach damit, wie es ist.
Das zeigt mir, dass es
wahrscheinlich schon gut ist.
(Frau) Janusch,
möchtest du nicht aussteigen?
Nein.
- Nicht?
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Janusch jedenfalls geht es gut,
das ist offensichtlich.
Tschüss.
Danke.
Nicht ins Taxi rein.
Tschüss, Janusch. Tschüss.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ein Jahr später:
Janusch wird sechs Jahre alt.
Ein paar Tage zuvor hatte auch
sein kleiner Bruder Arvid Geburtstag.
(Alle) # Happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday to you.
- Janusch.
# Happy birthday, lieber Janusch,
happy birthday to you.
* Applaus *
Ich habe schon.
- Hast du? Du kannst noch mehr.
Janusch ist schnell.
Super.
- Hat er alle? - Ja.
Gut. Bravo.
- Bravo.
* Sanfte Musik *
In einem halben Jahr
wird Janusch eingeschult.
Noch spricht er nur einzelne Wörter,
drückt sich mit Gesten
und Gebärden aus.
Die Fortschritte stellen sich ein,
aber nur langsam.
Das jedoch
scheint hier irgendwie egal.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023